you know and they were pretty much all
the building blocks or building a full
convolutional neural network let's look
at an example let's say that you're
inputting an image which is 32 by 32 by
3 so it's an RGB image and maybe you're
trying to do handwritten digit
recognition you know so you have a
number like 7 in a 32 by 32 RGB image
mean you're trying to recognize which
one of the ten digits from 0 to 9 this
is let's build a neural network to do
this and what I'm gonna use in this
slide is inspired it's actually quite
similar to one of the classic neural
networks called the net 5 which is
created by Yama could many years ago
what up show here isn't exactly the net
5 buttons inspired by it but many of the
parameter choices was inspired by it
so we're by 32 by 32 by 3 input let's
say that the first layer armed uses a 5
by 5 filter and let's try that one and
no padding so the output of this layer
if you use 6 filters would be 28 by 28
by 6 I'm gonna call this layer com1
right see the PI 6 filters Adebayor is
apply the non-linearity maybe a Rayleigh
non-linearity and that's the content 1
output next let's apply a pooling layer
so I'm going to apply max pooling here
and let's use a F equals to s equals 2
or when I don't write up adding a music
padding is equal to 0 next let's apply a
pooling where we're going to apply say
max pooling with a 2 by 2 filter and
stride equals 2 so this should reduce
the height and width of the
representation by a factor of 2 so 28 by
28 now becomes 14 by 14 and the number
of channels remains the same so 14 by 14
by 6 and when the call there's some
the pool one output so it turns out that
in the literature of a continent there
are two conventions which are in
slightly inconsistent about what you
call a layer one convention is that this
is called one layer so this would be
layer one of the neural network another
convention would be to count the con
Flair as a layer and the pool layer as a
layer when people report the number of
layers in your network usually people
report just a number of layers that have
weights that have parameters and because
the pooling layer has no weights has no
parameters only a few hyper parameters
I'm going to use the convention that
they come one and prove one here
together I'm going to treat that as
layer one although sometimes you see
people if you read articles online or
research papers you hear about the
contraire and the pooling layer as if
there are two separate layers but this
is a maybe two slightly and consistent
notation terminologies but when I count
layers I'm just going to come layers
that have weights so they treat both of
these together as layer one and the name
con one and pool one that when they use
here the one at the end also refers to
the fact that I view both of these as
part of layer one of the neural network
and and pool one is grouped into layer
one because it doesn't have his own
wings now let's apply another
convolutional layer to this I'm going to
use a 5x5 filter so F equals five and
try this one and you know but I don't
read them having a means there's no
padding and this will give you the
confidence your 16 filters so this would
be a 10 by 10 by 16 dimensional output
so maybe look like that
and this is the conf to layer and
let's apply max pooling to this with F
equals to s equals to your prey gets the
output of this 10 by 10 by 16 what max
pooling with F equals to s equals 2 this
will half the height and width you can
pretty guessed the result of this right
well max pooling with F equals to s
equals to this should half the height
and width so you end up with a 5 by 5 by
16 volume same number of channels as
before I'm going to call this pool 2 and
in our convention this is layer 2
because you know this has a 1 set of
weights in the count of 3 we're now 5
point 5 by 16 5 times 5 times 16 is
equal to 400 so let's now fatten our
pool 2 into a 400 by 1 dimensional
vector you also think of this as flatten
this out into just a set of neurons like
so and what we're going to do is then
take this 400 units and let's build the
next layer as having 120 units so this
is actually our first fully connect to
layer I'm going to call this F C 3
because we have 400 units densely
connected to 120 units so this fully
connected unit this fully connected
layer is just like the single neural
network layer that you saw in causes 1 &
2 it this is just a standard neural
network where you have a weight matrix
that's called w3 of dimension 120 by 400
and this is called fully connected
because each of the 400 units here is
connected to each of the 120 units here
and you also have a bias parameter yes
that's going to be just a 100
20 dimensional because if 120 outputs
and then lastly let's take 120 units and
add another layer this time a little bit
smaller but let's say we have 84 units
here we're gonna call this fully coming
to layer 4 and finally you now have 84
roll numbers that you can feed to a
softmax unit and if we're trying to do
handwritten digit recognition you know
to recognize is it the Hammerton 0 1 2
and so on up to 9 then this would be a
softmax with 10 outputs so this is a
reasonably typical example of what a
convolutional neural network might look
like and I know this seems like there
are a lot of hyper parameters we'll give
you some more specific suggestions later
for how to choose these types of hyper
parameters maybe one guideline is to one
common guideline is to actually not try
to invent your own settings of hybrid
parameters but to look in the literature
to see what hyper parameters you work
for others and to just choose an
architecture that has worked well for
someone else
and there's a chance that will work for
your application as well I will say more
about that next week but for now it
doesn't point out that as you go deeper
in the neural network usually an H and W
the height and width will decrease
quantities are earlier but it goes from
32 by 32 to 20 by 20 to 40 by 40 into 10
by 10 to 5 by 5 so as you go deeper
usually the height and width will
decrease whereas the number of channels
will increase gone from 3 to 6 to 16 and
then you're fully connected layers at
the end and another pretty common
pattern you see in neural networks is to
have cons layers maybe one or more
conflicts followed by proving layer and
then one or more convalesce followed by
pooling layer and then at the end to
have a few fully connect to layers and
then followed by maybe a soft max and
this is another pretty common
Pattin you see in new networks so let's
just go through for this new network
some more details of what are the
activation shape the activation size in
the number of parameters in this network
so the input was 32 by 32 by 3 and you
multiply out those numbers you should
get 3 0 72 so the activation you know a
0 has dimension 3 0 72 was really 32 by
32 by 3 and there are no parameters I
guess in the input layer and as you look
at the different layers feel free to
work of the details yourself these are
the activation shape and yet duration
sizes of these different layers so
doesn't point out a few things first
notice that the pooling layers the max
pooling layers don't have any parameters
second notice that the conflate tend to
have relatively few parameters as we
discussed in an earlier video and in
fact a lot of the parameters tend to be
in the fully collected layers of the new
network and then you notice also that
the activation size tends to maybe go
down gradually as you go deeper into
neural network if it drops too quickly
that's usually not great for performance
as well right so starts in the first
there were 6,000 and you know 1,500 600
and then slowly falls into 84 until
finally you have your soft max output
and you find that a lot of confidence
will help you know properties will have
patterns similar to these so you've now
seen the basic building blocks of neural
networks of convolutional neural
networks the conflate the pooling layer
and the fully connected layer a lot of
computer vision research has gone into
figuring out how to put together these
basic building blocks to build effective
neural networks and putting these things
together actually requires quite a bit
of insight I think that one of the best
ways through the gain intuitions about
how to put these things together is to
see
number of concrete examples of how
others have done it so what I want to do
next week to show you a few concrete
examples even beyond this first one that
you just saw on how people have
successfully put these things together
to about very effective neural networks
and through those videos next week I
hope they'll help you hone your own
intuitions about how these things are
built as well as give you concrete
examples of architectures that maybe you
can just use you know exactly as
developed by someone else or your own
application so we'll do that next week
but before wrapping up this week's
videos just one last thing which is one
a talk a little bit in the next video
about why you might want to use
convolutions some of the benefits and
advantages of using convolutions as well
as how to put it all together how to
take a neural network like the one you
just saw and actually train it on a
training set to perform image
recognition or some of the sauce so that
let's go on to the last video of this
week